hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast differential abundance
analysis for microbial marker gene
surveys it is presented by Joseph
Paulson PhD or research fellow at the
Dana Farber Cancer Institute I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots lab roots
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Paulson I will now turn the presentation
over to him
hi everyone thank you Judy for that
introduction
so I recently joined Genentech but
everything that I'm going to present
today is work from work that I've done
at dana-farber or that I've done at the
University of Maryland beforehand and
I'm going to talk about differential
abundance analysis of marker gene
service and really the overarching theme
it's applicable to not just for
microbiome or metagenomic acids but
these are approaches that are sparse
aware there are approaches that are that
can account for the sparsity for the
zeros that are in that count matrix when
one is doing an analysis and so I'll
talk I'll jump into it and give a little
bit of a background after sequencing
typically you go ahead you curate
whether you're using chime or mother or
one of these tools to go from reads to
count matrix for the analysis this is
where where you would step in and start
using these sparse aware methods and so
the overarching theme really for for
this talk is about the missing
information and technical artifacts if
present is ubiquitous really in marker
gene surveys 16s amplicon sequencing and
also ubiquitous in whole metagenomic
shotgun sequencing
and there there's actually there are as
single cell sequencing is coming about
and this might be it's not validated but
it might be applicable or sparse aware
methods and approaches might be
applicable as well in those in that
arena so but the majority of the talk
today is really going to focus in on the
microbiome and in particular and 16s
sequencing I'm going to highlight
several several old papers actually now
and try to tease tease the audience with
some more recent development that I'm
happy to answer questions about and/or
present at it at a future in the future
so so one more one more time really
everything is about what's missing
with the human microbiome project and
even before this as we were starting to
look at different micro microbial
communities when I was first before this
paper before the microbiome project came
out I was analyzing a big thousand
sample thousand patient cohort where we
had done 16s sequencing and we just
noticed that there were so many zeroes
in the matrix here I'm plotting the
read-depth
from all the samples all the 16s samples
in the human microbiome project along
the x-axis so that's the sequencing
depth are approximate the number of
reads within the count matrix and along
the y-axis are the number of ot use
operational taxonomic units that were
detected and you see this nice linear
trend that as you sequence more deeper
you observe more in general right it's
not always the case but there's a strong
correlation there that as you as the as
the technology this was actually four
five four but whether it's alumina or no
that I don't remember which technology
this was I believe it was for fiber but
as you sequence deeper more you get more
and more refuse you discover more
bacteria now if you look at the bottom
left corner right you see a lot you see
a bunch of samples over by zero zero
those those particular samples were they
have very few leads as they have maybe
one two three four five reads and they
also have detected only one or two or
five ODU's you would not imagine that a
particular sample a particular patient
is these were some of these work done
right you would not imagine that a gut
sample has only five bacteria in there
so that in that particular instance
right you would imagine it's a technical
artifact
but as you move along the x-axis and you
get into higher sequencing depth right
you observe more and more bacteria and
so what we want to do we want to take
into account the sequencing and
technical artifacts due to the
technology due to either low sequencing
depth or high sequencing depth and we
want to develop statistical approaches
to account for that and to estimate the
probability whether or not a 0 belongs
to some sort of technical distribution
that ok there wasn't there was an
earthquake and the sequencing machines
didn't actually spit out enough
information or that particular run went
really well and we expect that all the
zeros in the matrix I'll go over this
again in in a couple of slides but all
the zeros are real biologically
meaningful absent bacteria so these are
the main issues that are really present
in microbiome marker gene service at
least for me from an analysis standpoint
and it seems to be a trend coming out
with single cell sequencing another
other asset that might or might not be
relevant so typically you go through you
collect your samples you run them in the
wet lab you get your FASTA for fast
queue files and you process them now
everybody's doing my fake or let's say
even high seek you run it through let's
say for example the time to pipeline
which strings together all these
different tools
for creating in a in abundance table
traditionally chime - in particular uses
of different methods they use that a to
by default but traditionally you would
have ot you clusters so you would use
the Reid similarity from each of the
different samples so for example here we
have three different individuals where
they have red blue and green bacteria
and based off of a particular
representative Reid so one of those red
reeds you can calculate what the
distance is from each of the from that
Reid to all the other reeds and you
define usually it's at the 97 percent
similarity you define a cluster so if
you look at those little dotted circles
to the right you define a cluster of
what is what defines an OTU or an
operational taxonomic unit you then use
these and I won't go into the reasoning
a lot of it is for sequencing artifacts
and technical noise but you take these
representatives sequencing centers and
you map them against a 16s data base for
doing annotation or you can do your
analyses at the ODU level so for example
is back to this repertory representation
we have reads from each of the three
samples and it happened to be that we
had three three reads that were read
these were from bacteria read that were
present in sample one you see the first
column the first row in the second
sample in second patient we had four
reads representative for red bacteria in
there and in the third set a third
patient we happen to have five red reads
so you then look and you count up how
many read reads you have an example yeah
and you build this matrix really this
matrix of ot use of red blue green
ABC ot use so along the along the rows
by samples along the columns
and so the final output really is where
we have ideally thousands of samples
along the column right and one can
imagine you have multiple groups right
you might have a healthy and a diseased
group where you have maybe a couple
hundred ideally or maybe maybe you let's
say you even have just ten you have ten
samples in Group one and ten samples in
group 2 and you have ot use if we're
you're talking about 16s we're talking
about thousands of oh to use or if
you're using data to new pipelines you
might even just have hundreds
of operational taxonomic units along the
rows and each value within that matrix
represent the number of reads within the
particular
otu that came from a particular
individual apologies if I'm repeating
myself but this is probably the most
important point to take home that this
is the this is the starting point for
many of the analyses and that I that I
do and that I then use R and I develop
our packages for an app analyzing this
type of data and in particular I'm
interested in I'm going to present
differential abundance testing and so
what that means is where we take a
particular owed to you or to particular
species what if we aggregate up or a
particular genus and we do a comparison
of the abundance of the bacteria in
Group one and we compare it to grab the
group two so you can imagine the
hypothesis testing R is the average
abundance in Group one equal to the
average abundance in group two is e coli
more abundant in healthy or in diseased
individuals so
that's that's a little bit on the
background for for this and this is a
picture that I took from a slide from a
prominent researcher in the field and
there's been a lot of hype about the
microbiome right now and some of it is
just much of it is justified some of it
is not and but everybody is talking
about how the dysbiosis of gut
microbiota
is related to inflammatory bowel disease
rheumatoid arthritis potentially
depression ms asthma colon cancer all
these other different issues but people
tend to forget that it's directly linked
to infectious disease and what I'm going
to talk about is one of the earlier
studies that I was luck very fortunate
enough to work on and that's diarrhea
diarrhea there's a directly understood
and essentially even obvious connections
to the microbiome right it's a pretty
it's often a particular bacteria causing
the disease in the gut
and and understanding the dynamics of
that got bacteria that a causal agent
for diarrhea for this inflammation is
just a great testing ground for
understanding the microbial communities
in home
so I was recently just at UCLA and
diarrhea and you know in the Western
world you often think about it as just
being a nuisance but it's much more than
a nuisance in the majority of the world
and there are currently 800,000 deaths
from diarrhea I was just at UCLA the
other day and it's about 18 times the
population of the entire campus but
800,000 deaths a year and it's just
something that if we could take if we
have a better understanding you know
potentially we could do intervention or
we can do better testing or testing of
alternate bacteria and so that was a lot
of the motivation behind this
approximately one in five children under
the age of two they happen to suffer
from an episode of moderate to severe
diarrhea and these children are really
eight and a half times more likely to
die within two months of having
diarrheal disease there are there's a
relationship between growth and how
growth is stunted compared to peers over
the same two month period so it really
has it really has a huge impact on the
development of these children diarrhea
we we have characterized diarrhea and we
know that there are viral agents
bacterial agents and eukaryotic agents
using 16s it's only possible to
characterize really the bacterial but
until now and until the study it had
been known that Shigella is a is a
probably the largest of the different
diarrheal
cause allegiance I think it causes about
20% but Shigella salmonella
Campylobacter jejuni era Moniz Vibrio
cholera and then various dire dire rate
of gentleness
ecoli like etag are known to cause
diarrhea so there are many known causal
bacteria but what we did as part of the
global entire multiverse study there
were a few so this was a gate a large
Gates Foundation funded project across
seven different types there were a
number of sites four of them the Gambia
Mali Kenya and Bangladesh that really we
had a molecular sub study we collected
stool samples for the 16s targeted
amplicon sequencing and we decided to
assay these samples at this point we
have about three and a half thousand
patients so these are children three and
a half thousand but we reported a couple
of years ago on the first thousand and
so you can look forward to the follow-up
study on the remaining three and a half
thousand but so we published this study
in genome biology about diarrhea and
young children from low-income countries
that really leads to large-scale
alterations in intestinal microbiota we
back then we use the unfortunately gone
for five for flex sequencing technology
of this v1 v2 hypervariable regions it's
important to note that we chose to use
v1 v2 as opposed to v4 which is standard
with the Lumina kit primarily because we
did not care about factories and we were
focused on pathogen detection and the
v12 we felt had a better representation
or would be we better be better able to
speciate and identify particular
pathogens that we wouldn't with v-form
and this was a cross-sectional study
where we had a thousand stool samples
from children under the age of five
where half of them had moderate severe
diarrhea and the controls were defined
we tried matching to the best of our
ability within the same site but the
match control the almost match controls
were children with no diarrhea within
the last seven days so there were a
number of questions that we really
wanted to answer with this
how does composition of the microbiota
differ by country and by age how does
the composition and co-occurrence
different children with diarrhea and the
main question that we had to develop new
approaches to analyze the data were if
we could identify bacterial species that
are associated with diarrhea and that's
where we had to develop novel physical
methods and normalization approaches for
detecting differentially abundant
species so I'm going to I'm going to
still the being spoil it a lot basically
the question as to whether or not we can
identify bacterial species and yes we
can we can apply presence/absence
statistics
so using ones and zeroes defining some
threshold for presence and absence we
can for example do Fisher's exact test
that's one approach or you build a
contingency table and you say what are
the odds
of this particular bacteria or OTO or
species or genus beings in cases
compared to controls additionally we can
we develop the abundance dependent
statistics to test for if there's a
difference in the abundance right maybe
the presence absence doesn't matter
maybe there's a ubiquitously present
bacteria but if it's at a particularly
high abundance then it triggers this
cascade of inflammation so we found a
number of odd to us that were positively
associated with diarrhea according to
all the different statistical tests that
we that we measure we found granular
Katella which is known to cause swine
dysentery and we found some
streptococcus mitis and ammonia groups
that were really previously
uncharacterized and unassociated where
not had not previously been associated
with with diarrhea and and we we also
recovered in abundance dependent methods
cat Campylobacter jejuni and a sherry
Shigella i should point out that esther
Asia and Shigella according to the 16s
you can't really tell the difference
right because they are the same so ended
as a little teaser I'm working on a
study right now where we're trying to
compare neonatal sepsis patients that
develop hydrocephalus and there's an
ongoing project with dr. Schiff Steven
Schiff comparing samples from a
patient's neonates from Ambala and umber
ara in Uganda so some exciting new work
that's coming out that we're using 16s
sequencing for as well
and so yeah so essentially when when we
first started analyzing this data we
applied the very popular statistical
methods we didn't want to reinvent the
wheel basically we applied methods that
were have been abused in microarrays and
for RNA seek data applied edge our and
everything with significant applied DC
and nothing was significant there wasn't
enough power and that's because when
you're dealing with these large sample
sizes and there are a lot of
distributional characteristics that are
innate to the data that just really
don't convey the characteristics of the
data right so we needed to develop novel
approaches normal both normalization so
although over normalization and the
actual testing framework for testing
these different weather bacterias more
abundant in one group versus another and
estimating more robust fold change
estimates and that's because this is
where slowly we're still in the wild
wild west when it comes to the
microbiome right slowly now over the
last decade I've seen it shift we're
slowly we're no longer just exploring
we're actually looking at mechanistic
patterns and so I don't know if I'll be
able to use this what I thought have
thought is an amazing slide but I don't
know if I'll be able to use this slide
much longer but for now I think we're
still we still are in the wild wild west
of it all right and feature is that's
partly because features features being
the taxes of bacteria they're unknown a
priori we don't like do it often you're
doing this to clustering right it's
based off of read similarity and these
bacteria are not necessarily within the
databases okay and there are other
issues like I said before that
tickler OTU matrix that I analyzed with
the Gates Foundation you can download it
from bioconductor right now and it's 98
98 percent of the cells of the values in
that matrix are zero
and and that's highly representative of
a large assayed of many sample assayed
microbiome microbiome experiment stool
experiment and so we still want to get
meaning out of this table but with 98%
of the matrix being zero how informative
can that be
there is preferential sequencing certain
bacteria
it appears really just happen to go to
the PCR amplification process better
and I then sequence preferentially the
potential sub groups that you really
want to control for so you want to
appropriately model with your favorite
but statistician and you want to
collaborate with your favorite
statistician ideally help them help them
earn a living and control for sites
gender countries so and so forth and
because of this we have a large number
of features and so you always want to
control for multiple testing and account
for your type 1 error so first I'll go
into the normalization aspect and the
normalization approach that we we
develop on the left is a cartoon image
of the account matrix representing the
Rose being gene and where this is RNA
seek data and the columns are
representative of the of the various
samples on the right are the is a
representative cartoon of metagenomic
data where the rows happen to be the OT
use right and the columns are still the
samples and the green shades I'm not
sure if it comes through for everybody
but the green shade represents a
positive value so something greater than
zero and you'll see on the RNA seek it
RNA seek data is definitely more sparse
there are more zeros than this cartoon
says I'd say maybe 30% depending on the
experiment are zeros but in meta
no mcc's it really is that there's a
huge difference between between these
that and oftentimes all see 90% zeroes
or higher in metagenomics but so what
RNA seek data what one approached it in
particular there's a number of different
normalization methods one approach so I
would define normalization in two ways
there's either scaling normalization
that's where you divide by a single
value or there's global transformation
so an example of scaling value
normalization is where you divide by the
column sums so you would get proportions
so you divide by the library sizes okay
other approaches are for and that would
give you the relative abundance and
everybody in the microbiome is reporting
relative abundance for different
communities and it's important to do
that other normalization methods make it
different technological and biological
assumptions for example in microarrays
it's very popular to do quantile
normalization and that's where the
assumption is that the count
distributions or the the the
distributions for each sample are meant
to be similar right but that there are
only different due to technical noise
and so you force all of the
distributions to be the same so that's
an example of global normalization there
are a number of approaches there's TMM
which is used by edge ours there's RLE
used by dec two there and then there's
also library size for proportions but
same dream dude was group over at
Berkley highlighted in with a spiking
experiment of wild AK how RNA in RNA
seek data using library size proportion
was invalid and because it led to great
false positives and greater false
negatives and instead what they observed
was that the low-to-medium quantiles of
the low-to-medium quantiles of the
account distribution behaved similarly a
cross sample and that it was really at
the tails of the distribution the really
high abundances that destroyed that
destroyed the
that destroyed the characteristics that
we were that varied across across
different samples and so with that idea
what they decided was to scale each
sample by the 75th quantile and in that
way you're controlling for all the
different values you're controlling for
the technical variability the technical
variation in sequencing for each of the
samples so here on the Left we have the
original matrix and what they would do
is they would calculate for each
individual sample what is the 75th
quantile of the samples count
distribution and that particular values
a dark shade of green would become the
normalization factor used for scaling
followed by log transformation to be the
normalization constant alternatively we
we observed similar things in our data
that the low-to-mid quantiles of the
count distributions of the positive
count distribution behave similarly
cross samples but it was really the
tails it's these particular bacteria
that are very very abundant after
sequencing that are absorbing and
probably getting preferentially
sequenced that are getting all the
sequencing going on that are really
biasing the proportion so when if you
were to use proportions right you might
down scale certain bacteria that are
equally abundant across samples but
because there was one particular you
know a few samples that got a lot more
sequencing they they were and the the
most abundant bacteria were
preferentially sequence you're going to
get proportions that are not comparable
and not representative so instead we
decided to follow same ring to dois
through our group and we calculated we
we felt that a 75th quantile it wasn't
always appropriate value so we decided
to use a data driven approach to
determine what at what quantile do most
of the samples deviate from the
reference being the reference
representative of the entire data set so
at what point do the quantiles really
shoot off from the from the average of
the entire data set and also instead of
just using that particular quantile
value within a sample scaling and
summing up all the values from the
low-to-mid quantiles
up until that particular quantile the
other example I'm using that thumb as
the scaling normalization approach
so and that's that's that's represented
here where you have the original on the
left you have the original matrix you
sort the values the positive values and
you calculate the the the quantile and
you sum up the values up until that
quantile for each of the samples
what happened was we took as a
representation of why this normalization
approach works we applied we applied it
to a particular an older data set by
hitter turned off where they had two
sets of mice said the same diet for a
couple of weeks and then one group of
mice they introduced a new low-fat
polysaccharide rich diet so or sorry
they went from a low-fat polysaccharide
rich diet to a Western I like to call it
the McDonald's diet
and here each of these plots ABCD we see
different approaches for normalization
and in the a the one highlighted is my
particular approach called cumulative
some scaling normalization where you see
that it were better controlling the
technical variation and highlighting the
biological variability there and you can
also download this particular data set
from bioconductor so it was with D seeks
are led normalization and with TMM and
total sum you get some separation but
it's not it's not as representative and
it's not controlling the technical
variability as well
additionally we made use of linear
discriminant analysis and we were better
able to predict whether or not a
particular Mouse came from the Western
cohort or from the low-fat
polysaccharide rich diet
shift gears a little bit from
normalization though there's there's
been lots going back and forth about
normalization especially around
surrounding pseudo counts
and my argument about that is if you're
going to include a pseudo count I would
recommend using one so the pseudo town
is where you take the count matrix and
you add one to everything followed by a
law of transformation and because if
you're going to be doing PCA analysis so
that's what's represented here these are
PCA or multi-dimensional scaling class
they allow you to see the most variable
components in a data set which here you
see that the greatest variability
happens to be biology if you're going to
do add less than one what's happening is
when once you log transform you're
mapping a zero value to a negative and
so the greatest variability is going to
be between what is present and what is
not alright so at this point I'm going
to shift two of the hypothesis testing
of differential abundance where we're
looking at for example just ot u3 and
we're looking at if ot u3 is more
abundant in Group one or in group two
I'm going to remind everyone how we're
looking at what is the differential
abundance we're good we want to make use
of that linear relationship between
sequencing depth and the number of
detected features so we want to take
make use of this
the linear trend and which end it's
really a Bernoulli process right
bacteria is present or it's not and it's
related to how much sequencing was
output so what we did we at the time we
decided to make use of a zero inflated
Gaussian mixture model essentially what
that is is we apply a sample we estimate
the probability that is that a
particular value or a particular sample
particular samples otu comes from either
the tick detection distributions so a
spiced mass M 0 if you look at that
little distributional cartoon on the far
right there's a like a little I don't
know lamppost right that is like the
technical spike map technical
distribution so it's detection
distribution for zeroes this is for 1 or
2 right and so we estimate what what's
the probability that is 0 in a sample
given a samples depth of coverage or
sequencing depth what's the probability
that it came from technical noise so
somebody kicked the sequencer and the
sequencer decided not to spit out a lot
of information or that it was truly
present and attaint comes from this
particular biological distribution which
we at the time we simplified in made use
of adaption
so we modelled all the data as coming
from the 0 inflated Gaussian mixture
model - and we make use of the
probabilities that is 0 belongs to the
biological distribution to get better
more robust to full change in variance
estimates or the differential abundance
testing here's a little cartoon for
those that are more quantitatively
inclined I'm not going to go over it but
essentially in the dark green you have
your observations so Y IJ are going to
be your observed counts KJ are going to
be is the status let's say case control
and SJ is the sequencing depth so using
those three we can model what our two
distributions so our two distributions
are the spike mass at zero the two light
yellows - y y0 the spike mass at zero
and y1 which we model as a Gaussian and
the Delta IJ is so the gray we can
estimate using posterior using our
logistic using the logistic and an
expectation
maximization algorithm the details
around the paper what the posterior
probabilities are for a zero belonging
to one or the other of the distribution
and then the light graze on the far
right we can estimate the full change
estimates variance and baseline
estimates for each Oh to you for a
graphical explanation here if you look
at one particular row I'm presenting
randomly katella pair addition from sub
gingival plaque and tongue dorsum on the
Left we have kernel density estimates
for the if you look at the read it's sub
gingival plaque if you look at the blue
we have tongue so and we see a
difference between the two groups right
is this particular bacteria is more
abundant in the tongue
so without you without accounting for
the sequencing depth on the Left we have
we see that there's a large difference
however a lot of the samples that from
the sub gingival plaque happen to be
patients or individuals these one
patients live HM pcs we're all healthy
volunteers these these individuals
it just so happens that a lot of these
samples had lower sequencing depths now
and we believe that that in part was due
to technology not necessarily not
necessarily biological once you account
for the zeros of account for sorry once
you account for the sequencing depth you
see that the kernel density shifts right
those samples are down our estimated
lower or down waited and we see that
there still is a difference between the
sub gingival plaque and the tongue
dorsum but that that difference is more
attenuated there's not a more moderate
difference between the two groups so it
is still there but it gives us a more
robust estimate of that full change and
so we compared from here our Manhattan
plots where is every positive spike
represents a the abundance within a
particular group within a particular
sample sorry for this electro Pia oral
clone where on the Left we had 120
samples so you'll see 120 lines there of
the abundance for the slit Rokia in
south gingival plaques individuals
versus tongue individuals and so we see
that litter Opia was highly present and
highly abundant in in the sub gingival
plaque whereas in comparison it was not
a president at all in tongue and so when
we did a particular analysis with for
example let's see at the time because
one approaches to do all these multiple
comparisons we included site information
and there is there is a batch effect
those - dotted lines in the figures
represents the sequencing center so you
can actually see in the sub gingival
plaque one of the sequencing centers
didn't see any of practically any
literal
during subjuntivo 5 but in either case
if you include that variable in Leslie
for example you don't observe any
differential abundance for this
particular organism but you do when
applying meta-genome sleep our approach
that encompasses the normalization and
differential abundance analysis coming
full circle
we were we were able really to also
highlight granular Katella which I
already said is known to cause swine
dysentery and we were able to find her
species as well that are not only
associated and are being tested with
ti-84 cell and TI you know epithelial
cell lines and other cell lines and the
animals if the associations are causal
so now you can look forward also to a
whole move framework there were issues
with having a two hive false discovery
rate so too much power and we want to
curtail the false positive rate and so
we restructured it under the hood and
now within meta-genome seat there's
actually a fit feature model function to
allow for is your inflated log normal
and this is different from a zero
inflated Gaussian distribution that a
lot really allows for much faster
computation because there's no need for
an expectation maximization algorithm
and it really I think it's it's superior
to the older approach but all these
approaches and methods are within
bioconductor in a package called
meta-genome seek that really encompasses
the full statistical framework that i've
highlighted here and the utility in
doing some quick and dirty analyses
philo see a very popular bioconductor
package for microbiome data also feeds
in and there are rappers to creating met
seek objects-- to do these different
analyses
so I recommend meta-genome speak more
for larger studies there's a large
infrastructure and data set of data
packages for example this whole data set
that I described is available in a
package called MSD 16s there is one
where we challenged individuals with
entero toxigenic atresia called it
attack 16s but revolving around this
meta-genome seek package there are a
number of visualization and
infrastructural components and packages
that you can be on the lookout for
meta-genome features was just finished
and we have a paper and submission that
will allow for exchanging of annotation
of 16s data between Greenjeans Silva RDP
there's formatting packages one of them
being biome format that will incorporate
loading to our biome files that I worked
with the Philo seek authors Joey
McMurray on
and then there are visualization tools
one of them being meted is that came out
I think a month ago in nucleic acids
led really by Justin Wagner oh I want to
do a quick shout-out meta-genome
features was built by Nate Olsen in
Hector parada Bravo's lab did a great
job on that and other developments and
then meta vis really led by Justin
Wagner this really cool interactive and
statistical and visual analysis of
metagenomic data that I hope lab roots
would invite Justin for a talk of going
forward really that has I think 70,000
samples loaded already into the
interactive visualization browser
essentially go to the links on this web
page and you can see and play around
with play around with some of the data
within the article itself there is
actually there are a couple of figures
that are static and you have you have
the ability to go and directly get
linked to them so as a roundup I just
want to highlight that with whenever
you're doing a microbiome analysis it's
because of the sparsity because of all
the zeros they're depending on the
sequencing site and other assay
characteristics it's very easy to find
batch and Center effects solely due to
what's missing
here I'm presenting fossa from the human
microbiome project and I can show from
HMP to and from other more recent
studies as well but there's a difference
in for the same particular body sight
that we don't have the way we don't have
using this particular data set a way of
characterizing whether it's due to the
individual or through the sequencing
center but I can tell you it's do the
sequencing center where we see that
there's a very large difference in the
fossa
okay here not necessarily because of the
overall proportion of positive reviews
but because of which Oh to use were
present in the wash used sequencing
center we see a large distribution oh
this is another PCA or and yet you can
think of it as a PCO a plot if you're
visualizing data if you know what that
is but it's another way to we see these
huge batch effects and so I highly
recommend maybe even instead of coloring
by sequencing center or batch your PCA
plots but maybe by shades of the
proportion of that of positive o to use
within a particular sample
simple here here's a more striking
difference wherein gingival epithelium
you can see differences in the
proportion of OTS by different by
sequencing centers so in the top left we
see the proportion of positive reviews
and bout as a boxplot format where JC VI
and green is at the bottom end and Wash
U as the in purple is at the top end and
when you do your PCA you see you can
really see where the two sites diverge
and they're at opposite ends of the PCA
plot in the first coordinate
is the bottom left we also see that PC
principal components are highly
correlated with sparsity and obvious
sequencing batch so just a little
cautionary tale and some other pieces
that are there's ongoing research for
and so I really just want to take this
time to acknowledge and think you know
all the people that have worked on this
and that I'm working with at the
University of Maryland me hi pop Hector
Prada Bravo Colin Stein at Penn State my
collaborators on the Uganda neonatal
sepsis project that I think some very
exciting work will come through and and
others
Thank You dr. Paulson
formative presentation we will now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time forms so let's
get started our first question is where
can I find meta-genome speak
so imagine MC is available at
bioconductor org you just search there's
a search toolbar at the top and you just
type in meta-genome seek and it should
be the first link it's yes it's it
should be easily findable even to Google
great thank you how do I install
meta-genome seek
so on the page when you go to
bioconductor go to the bioconductor
website for meta-genome see
there are actually there's a little gray
box that's going to highlight in are the
code necessary for installing so it says
installation says to install this
package start R and enter source file
see light meta-genome seed so copy and
paste those particular lines of code and
then you'll get you'll start installing
and it might take a few minutes ok we
have time for one more question and it
is is there a user guide for meta-genome
sake so every every particular
bioconductor package comes with a
vignette and there are two vignettes
associated with this
so there's browse vignettes as a
function with a capital v and then you
type in the function of the package name
in particular this would be meta-genome
see and you'll find the detailed
documentation on various functions and
guides voice and the instance not just
for installation but also for analysis
pipeline i would like to once again
thank dr. Paulson for his presentation I
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August
10th 2018 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye